[Music]
they are some of the most distressing
images of the invasion of the capitol
building
bloodied police officer daniel hodges
screaming out in pain
and begging for help recounting for the
first time what happened
he says he thought he wouldn't survive
someone managed to get his thumb in my
eye
my right eye and start gouging it out
thankfully i was able to shake him but
that was the second time where i'm
afraid of
you know that might be the end or i
might be maliciously disfigured
the footage of the chaos is still being
studied by investigators
and the intent of this mob is chilling
you know one of my ammunition magazines
was stripped from my belt
and guys were trying to grab my gun and
they were chanting like kill him with
his own gun
i could shoot him um
they're trying to kill me and i'm
justified
but if i did that i would provide them
with the justification that they
needed to kill me
but as some police officers are lauded
for their heroism
others are being investigated it's
thought some had a role in the chaos
the wider investigation is also
gathering pace
so far nearly 100 arrests
the authorities though are still trying
to identify more suspects
including the man wanted in connection
with the murder of police officer
brian sicknick and it's feared there
could be more attacks
in the days leading up to the
inauguration of president-elect
joe biden thousands of national guard
troops are fanned out across the capital
fortifying institutions we cannot allow
a recurrence
of the chaos in illegal activity that
the united states and the world
witnessed
last week
the storming of congress will go down as
one of the most dramatic security
breaches
in american history but along with the
failings there is also a story of
heroism
of those who stood their ground and
risked their lives
alex rossi sky news washington